google has a better sense of what we  prefer than we do and Google certainly  has a better sense of what we prefer  than our partners do III can vouch for  that in my marriage and think your kids  I mean Google will have a better sense  of even who they are than they might and  his recommendation is a practice of  meditation actually helps us understand  why we're doing the things that we're  doing why we react in the ways that we  do and it's important for us to have  that base level understanding and  self-awareness because otherwise we're  just off shooting every single decision  to these algorithms and then who are we  I mean it's it's the it's the wall-e  future that one of my favorite Pixar  movies that you know that that is the  future where we're headed to and I think  meditation is one of those tools that  that can at least make us aware of the  choices or we're making